the disgraced former president has
lobbed another attack on our sacred
democracy when he suggested that the
recent election was stolen and that the
winner was not legitimate and that
disgraced former president's name is
jimmy carter
there's no doubt that the russians did
interfere in the election and i think
the interference although not yet
quantified uh if fully investigated
would show that trump didn't actually
win the election in 2016. he lost the
election and he was put into office
because the russians interfere
on his behalf
so do you believe president trump is an
illegitimate president
based on what i just said which i can't
retract
behold the face of insurrection the
dangerous 150 year old demagogue who
dares to question our never corrupt and
always pristine electoral process donald
trump hillary clinton and jimmy carter
have now officially all refused to
accept the results of the same number
of elections when you look beyond
presidential candidates to congressmen
and governors terry mcauliffe the
sainted john lewis who rejected the
results of at least two presidential
elections the crowd gets a lot bigger
and skews by the way to the left
but the democrats fear-mongering about
insurrections and coup d'etat was never
legitimate it was always merely a way to
justify the censorship and ostracism of
half of the country and unfortunately it
seems to be working i'm michael knowles
as the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from squid vet
ohio who says hitler watching the view
on hell's streaming service must be
wondering what he's got to do to prove
that he's not a racist that is true
that's a true comment and it's
especially true because the view is
playing 24 7 in hell that is the only
program on hell's streaming service and
that that is one of the
the many torments that the damned must
endure now we we want to make sure that
we can protect ourselves our immortal
souls our temporal bodies and our homes
which is why you've got to check out
american home shield no one likes to
think about household breakdowns but
they happen and they happen way more
often than you would like which is why
it pays to have a plan from american
home shield to help cover the costs to
repair and replace things like your
heating system your ac and your fridge
they also know that no two homes are the
same that's why they have new options to
help you find just the right coverage if
american home shield can't repair the
covered item they'll replace it american
home shield members get more they get
more coverage options and fewer
exclusions from hvac systems and
plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
coverage is available no matter how old
your systems and appliances are
really important when you own a home
things break they break all the time
keep your home up and running and keep
your budget on track with american home
shield right now
our listeners can take fifty dollars off
their most comprehensive plans ever go
to
ahs.com knowles canadawlis to save 50
bucks that's ahs.com
knowles for 50 bucks off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details
speaking of the insurrection you know
the january 6th the insurance greatest
insurrection in american history there
is some footage that's been going around
the internet the past few days that i
think most people probably have not seen
this is from the the very heart of the
insurrection in the capital starring the
guy in the horn hat so this is the
leader one of the most notable faces
from that near coup d'etat that almost
took down our government viewer
discretion is advised
take a look at what nearly took down our
government
hey man
glad to see you guys you guys are
patriots look at this guy he's got
covered in blood god bless you
you good sir you need medical attention
i'm good thank you all right
i got shot in the face
i got shot in the face with some kind of
plastic bullet
any chance i could get you guys to leave
the senate wing
we will i've been making sure they ain't
disrespecting the place okay i just want
to let you guys know this is like the
sacred place
so you got the cop
walking in with these guys you got a few
of the alleged insurrectionists
including the horn hat guy
the cop is walking and he's like hey
guys you mind maybe just
if you don't mind could you come off the
podium thing okay all right that's fine
does not exactly look
like a revolution to me does not look
like an insurrection does not look like
a coup d'etat
does not look particularly violent or
dangerous it looks relatively orderly as
far as these things go and there was a
cop there escorting them the whole time
looks to me
like january 6 and all of the legal
threats and all of the congressional
investigations and the whole hullabaloo
was almost entirely
a media creation
if you
asked
100 people on the street what happened
on january 6th i bet 99
of those people would tell you there was
a violent
you know terrible insurrection at the
capitol
i bet maybe a few people would be more
skeptical but i don't i doubt a single
person maybe one person would tell you
that it looked like that
just
a bunch of jokesters kind of walking
around
not attacking police officers really not
killing certainly not killing police
officers not uh attempting to overthrow
the constitution not writing laws not
none of that
none of it
meanwhile there was a an insurrection
that very year right within the year of
january 6 there was there was an actual
insurrection called blm and antifa went
on for eight months or so there were
autonomous regions declared in in
different cities in america there were
dozens of people killed in political
violence by blm there were federal
buildings attacked it went on city after
city after city but we were told that
was mostly peaceful there's a wonderful
story just out of tennessee actually out
of my new home state
a black lives matter chapter founder in
tennessee was just sentenced to six
years in prison for illegally
registering to vote while serving
probation
according to the criminal court judge
you tricked the probation department
into giving you documents saying you
were off probation
why was this woman on probation she was
on probation pamela moses uh because in
2015 she was found guilty of a number of
felonies including tampering with
evidence forgery
misdemeanor charges of perjury stalking
theft under 500 bucks and escape
so the reason that i really love this
story
the reason the story is so delicious
is because it knocks down
two sacred leftist narratives one
that blm is not run by criminals
two that there is no illegal voting and
in this case
you've got the criminal blm chapter
founder illegally registering to vote
because both of those things are true
blm and antifa are run by criminals and
it's they are criminal enterprises
and they commit lots of crimes
and two there is obviously lots of
illegal voting this is why when the
democrats tried to pass their federal
law election takeover as the first order
of business for the house of
representatives and for the senate hr
one and s1
they
at one in out of one side of their mouth
they said that illegal aliens will not
be registered to vote you won't have
more illegal voters and then out of the
other side of their mouth they said and
when illegal aliens are registered to
vote they'll be given legal amnesty they
won't be they won't be prosecuted for
that well hold on if they're not going
to be illegally registered why do you
need to give them amnesty for it because
obviously it is the narratives that we
have been told are not true which brings
us
to joe rogan
which is actually probably the biggest
news of the day joe rogan
is a dangerous dangerous racist
disinformation peddler he wasn't any of
those things a week ago but now the left
has decided he is all of those things
because he has positioned himself not
even with the conservatives just sort of
against the left-wing narrative joe
rogan is a liberal he's a full-on
liberal he's not a conservative but he's
contradicting some of the leftist
narratives and so now joe rogan's got to
go according to them
so the mob makes up its own narratives
facts be damned
first they tried to get him on covid
disinfo the problem is that joe rogan
has been more correct about covid than
dr fauci joe biden and rachelle wolenski
combined so they couldn't really get him
on that so what did they do they dug up
some old clips of his show in which he
was quoting people using the n-word and
they called him a racist they tried to
insist this is always what they do they
insinuated that he was a racist
and unfortunately
joe has sort of kind of apologized
hello friends
um
i'm making this video to talk about the
most
regretful and shameful thing that i've
ever had to talk about publicly
there's a video that's out that's a
compilation of me saying the n-word
it's a video that's made of clips taken
out of context of me of 12 years of
conversations on my podcast and it's all
smushed together and it looks horrible
even to me now i know that to most
people there is no context where a white
person is ever allowed to say that word
never mind publicly on a podcast and i
agree with that now
i haven't said it in years but for a
long time
when i would bring that word up like if
it would come up in conversation and
stay instead of saying the n word i
would just say the word i thought as
long as it was in context people would
understand what i was doing like that
context was
part of the clip we were talking about
red fox how red fox said that word on
television in the 1970s and how times
have changed so much since then
so he's explaining why he did it the
explanation's perfectly fine but then
he's apologizing too and he's trying to
split this baby and he's trying to see
if he can put this cancel mob back into
pandora's box
i don't think
i don't think it's working i don't and i
think joe rogan's got to be very careful
here because this is going to have huge
effects not just for his show but but
actually this joe rogan podcast the way
he behaves now is going to have huge
effects for free speech in america
that's very scary there's a lot of
downsides to this culture this canceled
culture which is why i would recommend
you get upside gas is going through the
roof it's very very expensive and i can
save you
25 cents per gallon every time you fill
up that's actually that's not true
i i want to correct myself
i can actually get you
50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first fill up when you
download the free get upside app you get
the free get upside app you use promo
code knowles w l e s you will get 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
fill up and you'll get 25 cents per
gallon
on every fill up you make after that
it's very simple there is no cash there
is only cash back this goes straight to
your bank account or if you prefer
goes to an amazon gift card or gift card
to some other shop can go to paypal
however you prefer it's very very simple
people who drive a lot
are getting two to three hundred dollars
per year cash back right now download
the free get upside app use promo code
knowlescanwlis to get 25 cents per
gallon or more
cash back on your first tank that is
code knowles
joe rogan is apologizing for using the n
word
the word he didn't say the it's
confusing because it's the only words
you're not allowed to say but he didn't
say the n word he said the end you know
the word the actual the n word okay when
he was quote he didn't say it in anger
he didn't say you
he was just quoting other people or
discussing the context of it and he did
this many times over the years and no
one ever had any problem with it until
the liberal establishment wanted to go
after joe rogan for having the audacity
to question the exalted dr fauci who has
been completely wrong about almost
everything with the coronavirus and so
because joe rogan now demonstrably has a
better record on covid than the head of
the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases because of that now
they're digging up old clips out of
context and trying to insinuate that joe
rogan hates black people or something
like that and the problem is
joe is sort of apologizing
as a general rule
apologizing for out-of-context remarks
to people who have not been offended by
them and who do not care
is neither helpful nor good
it's not even the right thing to do but
it but beyond whether it's the right
thing to do or the wrong thing to do it
also won't help you i don't think it's
going to help people think it will help
them but it won't it'll actually hurt
them
i understand i have been the target of a
couple of cancel mobs in my life one of
which was pretty serious could have
taken down my career
and there were there were so many
incentives
to ju just to apologize yes it was out
of context yes no one was really
offended yes they're just using this as
a way to attack you yes yes it's not
whatever but just just apologize and
it'll all go away it won't go away it
won't that's not it's not gonna go back
to normal it's not gonna you're not
gonna be allowed to
just apologize and because it's not no
there's no not real repentance and real
grace here it's a completely contrived
situation and the minute that you show
them a little bit of your neck they're
going to hack your head off okay that's
what this is about you've it's i would
call this
the hank schrader rule and i think
joe rogan would do very well to heed the
hank schrader rule the hank schrader
rule comes from
breaking bad it's the scene where walt's
brother-in-law hank the cop
is killed and the rule is this
do not apologize to the mob do not
grovel to the mob
because the mob made up its mind ten
minutes ago
hank
said to me
you gotta tell me
you gotta tell them now that we can work
this out please
please
what you want me to beg
you're the smartest guy i ever met
and you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're gonna
do that's what happens and and hank was
right and walt was wrong walt's saying
no just apologize just say this will go
away and then we can all go back to
normal you can't go back to normal when
when the cancel mob asks for your
apology
they're not
trying to figure out what to do with you
they've already made up their mind
they're going to kill you
they're going to kill your career all
right their guy i hope they don't kill
you literally but they're certainly
going to kill your they've already made
up their mind
so the question is what are you going to
do now and that's the question for joe
rogan to make and unfortunately
i think spotify is pushing him in the
direction
of censorship
you don't you don't want to do that okay
the the internet is moving in a in a bad
direction right now it's moving in the
direction of censoring
perfectly fine perfectly good perfectly
true things there is one internet
company that's been around since the
very early days that will help you to
get incredible prices on travel that
would be priceline right now it can feel
like everyone is getting less less
social interaction less sunlight less
steps less time being in the office and
while that last one might not be so bad
don't you want more well since 1998
priceline has been the best way for
travelers to book the trip they want at
the price they can afford priceline
saves consumers more than one billion
dollars every year so that their
customers never have to miss the moments
that matter with priceline you can save
up to 60 on your favorite hotels and you
can also get exclusive deals on rental
cars and flights when you save more you
can do more more walks on the beach more
talking to strangers more fun
in the sun and no matter where you
travel
still less being in the office which is
always enjoyable there are few things
that feel as good as knowing that you
saved money with the discounts priceline
offers you get that feeling a lot
because you can save more and you can
enjoy more and you can do more
at priceline every trip is a big deal so
when you're ready to book your next one
you go to priceline.com for the best
deals that will help you get more out of
it there's a report out now
that uh as of saturday
113 episodes of the joe rogan podcast
have been taken down
uh rogan
reportedly made the decision himself
but this decision was made after
conversations that he had with spotify
it's very easy to judge joe rogan for
taking down his episodes right now you
say no you're giving in to censorship
you're giving in to cancel culture joe
rogan has a 100 million dollar contract
with spotify
100 million dollar contract and the the
thing about temptation
is that it's tempting that's what makes
it tough
and all of us who have who have given in
to many
less enticing temptations than a hundred
million dollars
all of us who
you know see a an extra drink at the end
of the night we can't say no or you see
a cute chick at the end of the bar you
can't say no or you see the extra plate
of turkey on thanksgiving you can't say
no
we're judging joe rogan for saying i'd
kind of like to keep the hundred million
dollars thanks
no the tough thing about temptation is
that it is tempting
the question is though what does joe
rogan want what does he want to have
happen now it seems to me the mob
already made up its mind spotify though
they're not firing joe rogan outright
they are appeasing the mob and they're
placing disclaimers on his episodes with
conservatives on the issue of kovid
they're taking down
over a hundred episodes apparently of
his show all the saucy
interesting episodes they're just taking
those down
they're saying that he needs to have way
more democrats they're neutering the
show they are neutering the show they've
already done it
they've already taken down the saucy
spicy stuff that the libs don't like
so then the question
for rogan is what kind of show does he
want
i don't know i can't answer that for him
i don't know joe rogan is a comedian he
was a sitcom actor a stand-up comedian
who became
probably the most trusted broadcaster in
america i i imagine he didn't expect
that but what kind of show does he want
the establishment is ordering things
such that he can be an insanely rich man
who will work for a very long time
doing a completely innocuous show
that doesn't rock the boat
or
he can be content just having a lot a
lot of money but not an insane but just
a lot a lot a lot of money
in doing the show that he wants to do
what do you want to do i don't know i
hope i hope that at a certain point of
wealth you say screw it i don't care
whatever
this is kind of what chappelle did dave
chappelle did this at comedy central he
was offered a crazy contract i think it
was 50 million dollars but it was to do
a show he didn't want to do he said
stuff it i've got enough money i'm going
to go do my own thing
what's he going to do it's going to
matter because
if they can do this to rogan
there is no reason that they should keep
any of the rest of our shows up on
spotify
ben
me
matt walsh
candice oh my gosh candace
any of the certainly any of the daily
why why are you going to keep us up
i like to think that the reason they'll
keep us up is because they don't want to
just shut out half of the country
for saying perfectly ordinary common
commonplace things
but if they're even going to go after
rogan who is a liberal
why wouldn't they go after us too
a lot is writing on this decision mr
rogan
i don't know joe rogan personally we
follow each other on twitter but a lot
is writing on this man i know it's tough
but
stand firm come on push back push back
please
speaking uh they you know they're going
to try to neuter the show speaking of
neutering
there is a disturbing tick tock
though as most of them are pretty
disturbing going around
uh it shows us the consequences of the
sexual revolution where a young woman
and her two
boyfriends i guess one's a husband and
then also her girlfriend discuss the
dynamics of their sexual polycule
hi my name is anna i am dating everybody
in the polycule i am married to jake
we've been together for eight years and
married for three i'm dating spencer
we've been together for three and a half
and i am dating ellie and we've been
together just over a month now i am
bisexual and my pronouns are she her
i'm also in charge of this account and
in general
hi i'm jake i'm married to anna and
she's currently my only partner
i am demiromantic which means i only get
feelings for people like romantic
feelings for people if i've been around
them for a while and get to know them
really well and i'm technically
pansexual but i like the bi-colors more
so i call myself bisexual
my pronouns are he
they
hi i'm ellie i'm dating anna i'm not
currently dating anybody else um i'm
some flavor of queer
and my pronouns are she her
i'm spencer i'm only dating anna um
i'm bi but like bi
so that this video goes we can cut it
there this video goes on spencer then is
asked what his gender is and he gets
confused and then he sees says gosh i
don't know and he's having and he looks
really lost i think we need to rescue
spencer the one i think we need to send
in a search and rescue team to go help
spencer
really all of these people are hedonists
and deeply disturbed people and
quite degenerate and they need to be
reformed and
improve their lives but spencer
especially seems very lost
the sexual revolution
has been an unmitigated disaster
for the human race
how can a society
go on
with that
where that is the understanding
of life
love
sex reproduction or the lack thereof how
can a civilization go on in that
unserious way where the men
are
wearing cat ears and proudly boasting of
how cuckolded they are
and the women are
i don't know they've all got these sort
of glazed out creepy eyes
that
everyone's marveling at at this kind of
sex and gender craziness as though it's
new oh it's so new we're in a brave new
world
but it's not new
it's this is just paganism this is just
this is what things were like before
christianity okay
and it wasn't great there's nothing new
under the sun folks
what is rare is not this breaking of all
the rules and all of the taboos and all
of the moral norms that we've had for
the past 50 years what's new is
civilization and we are throwing it away
for a polycule with creepy anna and her
cat-cuckled husband and her girlfriend
that she's known for a month and poor
spencer who doesn't know what gender he
is
also this thursday february 10th will be
the world premiere of shut-in daily
wires first original film at 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central over at the daily
wire youtube channel
this suspenseful thriller follows a
young mother trapped by her violent
ex-husband and his meth addict friend
and she must escape to save her children
before it's too late it's a tale of
redemption to the beat of a seat
gripping thriller the film premieres
this thursday february 10th at 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central over at daily wires
youtube channel make sure you click the
link in the description and turn on the
notification bell so that you don't miss
it because after the premiere it will
only be available to daily wire members
and before that world premiere make sure
you catch this week's episode of
backstage you join me ben shapiro jeremy
boring matt walsh and andrew clavin
thursday night at 7 30 eastern 6 30
central
over at you guest at the daily wire
youtube channel the premiere of shut in
starts at 9 pm eastern so that's on the
same channel be sure to tune in before
then we will see you very shortly
but we will also be right back with a
lot more
speaking of creepy sex stuff michael
avenatti
do you remember michael avenatti he is
the man that
we've all come to refer to as the creepy
porn lawyer the creepy porn lawyer
who
represented stormy daniels he kept
attacking trump he went on every cable
news channel on the left which is almost
all of them
for months and months he was talked
about as a possible
2020 democrat presidential nominee
michael avenatti was already convicted
of of a felony for trying to extort nike
but he was just convicted of another one
for uh stealing money from stormy
daniels his porn star client
so this this is the caliber of man that
the democrats will elevate on their
media platforms and they'll even talk
about him as a potential presidential
frontrunner the kind of dirtbag lawyer
who would rob his hooker client he was
spoken of so highly by the left that
anna navarro she's the fake republican
on the view but she's obviously a very
left-wing person anna navarro i kid i
don't even want to say it because it
seems sacrilegious even to observe what
happened
this
woman
compared michael avenatti to the holy
spirit
lately to me you're like the holy spirit
you are
all places at all times right
i mean you i do i see you all over cable
news i see you you know there is a uh
seat available if you want to be a
co-host at the view you might you know
there's people here you can pitch
this is the kind of person and it's this
is not just a one-off okay
what you're seeing here with michael
avenatti it's not just a one-off
think about andrew cuomo we're all
cuomosexuals oh andrew i've got a crush
on andrew cuomo he's the greatest
governor in america remember that
just a dirtbag corrupt politician chris
cuomo he is so respected over there don
lemon he hasn't fallen yet but their
foot shall slide in due time
oh jeff zucker the president of cnn that
guy's out also ostensibly for creepy sex
stuff even though it wasn't jeffrey
toobin
now i'm just talking about cnn the list
goes on and on and on outside these are
the kinds of people
that we are told are are the moral
arbiters of the universe
meanwhile joe rogan is is unclean joe
rogan is is lower than dirt
because why why because he
contradicted dr fauci
you're known by the friends you keep
okay
the the ladies on the view the cat i
don't i don't mean to use that term it's
disrespectful to ladies but the the hens
on the view
they're known by the friends they keep
cnn you're known by the friends you keep
the democratic party you're known by the
friends that you keep
and i i'm noticing a pattern here
michael avenatti to compare him how
disgusting to do that speaking of
ethical lapses
really disturbing report out about you
guessed it dr fauci the man that we're
not allowed to criticize the man who is
basically behind the
attempted assassination of joe rogan's
career
he's at least the he's the cause of the
attempted
assassination of joe rogan's career
there's a report out from the white
coast waste project white coat waste
project
not the white coast i don't know what
would that be part of the hamptons or
something uh that dr fauci's niaid
funds 80
of research involving human fetal cells
according to this investigation
the nih is actively funding over 27
million dollars of research approved to
use human fetal tissue
and they're expected to spend over 88
million dollars
total on human fetal tissue this year
and out of the current pool of just 27
million dollars 21.6 million has been
dispersed by dr fauci's department the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
in other words fauci is funding
around 80 of the current nih experiments
on
human fetal tissue that is cells derived
from murdered babies
this is this does not tie in with
fouchy's
uh corruption regarding kovid or his
incompetence regarding kovid or his
outright lies and even admitted lies or
even perjury regarding covid
this is a completely separate issue but
it shows you just more and more evidence
of this guy's ethical
issues
his lapses in judgment
this pattern that this guy's
understanding of ethics political ethics
medical ethics
his judgment is really compromised
which is why
you should not vote
for any candidate for federal office who
does not sign the michael knowles public
health protection pledge it's a very
simple pledge it's got two pieces to it
one that you will vote to investigate
subpoena investigate dr fauci two that
you will vote to zero out his salary you
can't fire him only the executive can do
that but you can zero out his salary
two parts we just had a number of i mean
we've had dozens and dozens of of
federal candidates sign this pledge uh
jd vance very well known candidate for
senate in ohio just signed it over the
weekend jd vance is the author of
hillbilly elegy a very serious senate
candidate there it's very simple we've
had many many other
candidates sign it as well you should
send the michael knowles public health
protection pledge to all of your
candidates your sitting congressmen your
senators send it to them and say sign
this or you don't get my vote this man
needs to be kicked out of his perch of
power speaking of corruption
in our public health establishment
jensaki was just asked about this johns
hopkins
working paper this study out of johns
hopkins it's a meta-analysis
of lots of other studies
they looked at thousands and thousands
and thousands of studies they narrowed
it down to 30 some odd studies that were
really really rigorous on the
effectiveness of lockdowns and they
found out that lockdowns not only don't
help to improve the public health not
only do they not stop
the spread of the virus or whatever we
were told that they were going to do not
only is the epidemiological literature
very clear on the ineffectiveness of
lockdowns from a public health
standpoint but from a political economic
social
standpoint even standpoints affecting
other areas of public health they're a
complete disaster they cause the
breakdown of society and lots of other
lots of other social problems so a
reporter asked jen saki about this study
and whether that has led the white house
to change its views on lockdowns
jensaki's answer tells you the whole
story about the study and about the
lockdowns real quick on the um johns
hopkins study on the lockdowns um it was
this meta-analysis that came out of
several studies
locked down during the first week of
coven in spring of 2020 found that it
only reduced covered mortality by 0.2
percent in the us and europe
um and suggested they have little to no
public health benefit but severe
consequences for the economy um and it
suggests that lockdowns shouldn't be a
part of a future pandemic response uh is
that the
shared view of the administration
looking in the rear view mirror well i
would say i would first of course point
you to our health and medical experts
for specifics on this specific
scientific study i would note that the
president has been clear we're not
pushing lockdowns we've not been
pro-locked down that has not been his
agenda most of the lockdowns actually
happened under the previous president
what our
objective has been is to conveying that
we have the tools we need to keep our
country open thanks to the president's
leadership and focus on fighting the
virus uh and that's reflected in the
fact that 98
of schools are open uh over 210 million
americans are fully vaccinated uh we
have the tools to avoid lockdowns and
we're not moving back and that's our
intention at this point
this is how you know
that the study is legit jen saki just
gave us the best evidence so far that
this meta-analysis from johns hopkins is
legit
because she doesn't even try to refute
it she actually does the opposite
she says no we never liked lockdowns no
we hate lockdowns
that's obviously bs the democrats and
and joe biden have supported all sorts
of draconian public health measures all
sorts of slow down don't go out stay
home don't do this lock up they of
course they've supported that
but they've got two choices here
they can either attack the study and say
no the lockdowns do work
or they can embrace the study and say no
we hate the lockdowns those are the only
two options they have if they want to
come out of this in a politically
advantageous way and they chose the
latter because they can't refute the
study because the study is clearly
rigorous
it it takes into account
dozens of other studies
and
and we know that the lockdowns are
useless
they're medically useless
politically they're very useful and
people are catching on to that now
now is the time
to push back on these officials
there's a woman
in prince william county in the school
district there she showed up to the
school board to to
grill the members of the school board
and to speak out against the
superintendent of the school board there
this woman had a great riff
on the inefficacy of masks
and the insanity of masking up the
little kids
but then she showed the political
corruption here too she pushed back
on the narrative that so many
politicians have leaned on which is look
there's nothing we can do we want look
we're just following the scientists look
we're just following we're just
following orders okay and so you got to
mask your kids up and and we just have
to go along and do it that's an excuse
they're they're hiding behind other
people to push policies that they want
and this mother has had enough
on november 15th of last year i had the
privilege of speaking with dr mcdade for
10 minutes following the crt town hall
meeting during that discussion which was
friendly and cordial i asked what she as
superintendent could do to get the kids
out of masks dr mcday told me that she
would if she could but that her hands
were tied by then governor northam's
executive order mandating face coverage
and if it weren't for that things would
be different well tonight things are
different
and i'd like to ask you dr mcday tonight
what has changed and what do you plan on
doing now that your hands are untied i'm
in fact i'm asking all of you to step up
the way other leaders who have who have
and are ending coveted restrictions by
the day what when will you what will it
take you are on the losing side of
history and it's time to make that right
before these children now thank you
[Applause]
be still my beating heart oh
my gosh oh i just
i just want to watch it again i want to
watch it on on loop you can see in the
board room that they're meeting in there
are all these big signs up in front of
the school they say thank you school
board
great job keep up the uh so what thank
you school board
it doesn't sound like those
parents in the audience are thanking the
school board
now in the room it's it sounds like
prime minister's questions out in in the
united kingdom
forget that it sounds like a wwe match
yeah wow yeah get him you drag him girl
it's so
there's obviously so much popular
support
for the parents
who are
taking control of their children's
education pushing back on these psycho
administrators and these leftist insane
politicians and saying no enough is
enough take off the stupid masks stop
trying to make me inject my kid with the
experimental drug to maybe possibly but
probably not protect against the virus
that doesn't pose any particularly grave
threat to them
shut up you awful superintendents and
your principals and your school board
members
and get out
because we're going to control education
now this is such a great issue
the people running the education system
are completely full of it
this is a great issue where it
kind of like joe rogan actually joe
rogan transcends political boundaries he
is a liberal but he appeals to lots of
conservatives he appeals to some
leftists and some bernie bros too he's
got a really kind of broad appeal the
same thing with this parents movement
it's got a really broad appeal
it it's not just the rock-ribbed
conservatives it's it's any mother
any parent who doesn't want their kid to
be victimized by psychos in school and
there's a whole lot of that going around
by the way
speaking of child abuse in schools
there is a video
making its way around the internet you
know i generally hate tik tok i
generally hate what social media has
done to the world however it is a good
way to shine light on abuses that are
going on and and some of these are
contrived some of these are
non-traverses ginned up to attack
someone like joe rogan for instance you
take a bunch of
short clips out of context and then you
use that as a way to to lead a digital
lynch mob to destroy this guy's career
but sometimes you see legitimate abuses
there's a school in dc that is now
forcing
elementary school students we're talking
about five-year-olds six-year-olds
to march around masked up of course
wearing
wearing the masks carrying signs that
say black lives matter and chanting blm
chance
if these students were forced to
walk around holding up a statue of the
blessed virgin mary enchanting the salve
regina
there would be
lawsuits it would it would
i would say it would go up to the
supreme court but it wouldn't because
that that would be shot downs at so much
so many of the lower courts you would
have teachers fired it would be a
national scandal
it would be a national scandal if
students were made to engage in
a religious ritual
for
good
traditional true religion for
christianity
but because the students are made to
march around holding up signs and giving
religious chance to the leftist secular
religion the blm religion
well that's perfectly fine that's
actually mandatory
obviously this thing should be illegal
blm is a terrorist organization founded
by marxists it's anti-american it should
be it should be
suppressed in the country
and it's it has no place in schools
obviously without question
but
we've got to go further in our thinking
of this we can't just i it really drives
me crazy when people say just keep your
religion out of politics you can't it's
not politics always is about religion
because it's always about morality and
it's always about how we view the world
so it's always going to be about
or they'll say keep politics out of
schools that's not possible politics
just refers to public things how we all
get along together the values that we
hold in common the way that we see
ourselves and each other and our country
you can't keep politics out of schools
certainly not out of public schools
politics political and public mean the
same thing there's synonyms
so you can't keep holiday the question
is not will we have religion in schools
the question is not will we have
politics in schools the question is what
kind of religion the question is what
kind of politics what will be tolerated
what will not be tolerated
right now if you read the bible in
schools if you if you teach the bible in
schools you will be
reprimanded and probably fired
if you read some marxist trash in
schools or ibram candy or critical race
theory if you teach that in schools you
will be rewarded
that often that will be part of the
curriculum
they're both
they would both be religious views it's
just one of them happens to be good and
true and essential to our civilization
and the other one is modern leftist
trash and unfortunately right now we're
elevating the thing that is false and
destructive
and and ugly
the leftist theories and we're
suppressing good true religion
same thing with politics we're going to
be taught politics
when you say america is a good country
america's done good things that's
politics when you say america is an evil
country
and it's a white supremacist country and
it's got structurally bigoted and
whatever that's politics too you're
always going to have the politics but
what are the politics going to be
our form of government is conducive to
justice that's politics our form of
government is deeply unjust that's
politics too you can't get rid of it
what is the politics going to be
we don't teach students what to think
only how to think that's that's another
one of these stupid slogans that doesn't
mean anything because all schooling
teaches students what to think
so what are we going to teach them
to think
if you say murder is wrong
you're teaching someone what to think
if you say that murder is okay if it's
done by blm and antifa you're teaching
them what to think too you're just
teaching them something that is wrong
we've got to grapple with that
question the schools are the
battleground where it's going on right
now and there was a photo that made the
rounds this weekend that to me it they
say a photo
an image
says a thousand words i think this image
says a hundred thousand words
it's an image of stacey abrams the
pretend governor of georgia remember
we're told it's evil and terrible and
destroys our sacred democracy if you
question election results unless you're
a democrat in which case it's wonderful
stacey abrams has been pretending that
she won her gubernatorial election for
four years now
and stacy abrams as part of her fake
gubernatorial tour
went around to an elementary school
and she took a photo with students all
the little kids
who are at statistically very low risk
if any risk from kovid they're all
wearing masks stacey abrams who is at a
significantly higher risk from cove but
it's still a very very low one but
higher all right let's uh put it that
way
she is not wearing a mask
because she's not really afraid of covid
none of the people who are telling you
to lock down and wear masks and take
them none of them are afraid of kovid
they just
want you to be afraid of covet and they
want to control you and she's sitting
there smiling grinning ear to ear
no mask all the little kids
have to mask up tells you everything you
need to know
about the masks and the politics of
kovit in one photo she gets called out
for it what does she do
she plays the race card she says it's
shameful that our opponents are using a
black history month reading event for
georgia children as the impetus for a
false political attack and it is pitiful
and predictable that our opponents
continue to look for opportunities to
distract from their failed records when
it comes to protecting public health
during the pandemic this pathetic
transparent and silly attack is beneath
anyone who claims they want to lead
georgia what are you talking about lady
you got caught in rank hypocrisy and now
you're playing the race card like the
left always does it's the exact same
thing that's happening to joe rogan
rogan has been has a much better record
on covet than any of the so-called
public health leaders some random
podcaster
weightlifter
is a has a better record than dr fauci
that's the state of our country right
now
and and he
he calls them out and the left doesn't
like that and they call him a racist
it's the exact same thing here
it's the exact same thing here and the
woman doing it here by the way also
questions the results of our elections
none of this
is sincere
none of these attacks are sincere they
do not deserve an apology
from us people who have not committed
any particular offense toward these
people the people who are attacking us
do not care they don't deserve an
apology what we have to do is stand firm
and fight back i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show we'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what good is this doing now
i'm scared
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
you